pero él
en este programa sobre las elecciones en
francia daremos una mirada por los
hechos más relevantes de la semana los
aspirantes presidenciales se enfocaron
en la agricultura y las pensiones
durante sus discursos a menos de 10 días
de la primera vuelta
el presidente y candidato de manuel bajo
enfrenta una polémica por el incremento
en los contratos con la consultora
mckenzie sus detractores lo acusan de
ser adicto al gasto que el gobierno se
defiende diciendo que las consultorías
eran para ayudar a manejar la pandemia
hablaremos también de por qué la
izquierda llega tan dividida en estos
comicios aunque uno de sus candidatos
sean look balance on ha crecido en las
encuestas los colectivos de este sector
político no están unificados y la
abstención podría ser determinante
bienvenidos a francia elige yo soy maría
clara calle y en la carrera final de
cara a la primera vuelta presidencial
los 12 candidatos se juegan sus últimas
cartas esta semana los aspirantes al
elíseo si intentaron conquistar a los
agricultores que son 15 por ciento de la
población en sus discursos también se
refirieron al polémico tema de las
pensiones veamos los hechos más
destacados de los últimos días
esta es la historia de las promesas
hechas a la comunidad agrícola inmersa
en un gran sufrimiento el candidato
comunista fabián hoss el amante
empedernido de la buena carne hace gala
de sus grandes ambiciones medio millón
de agricultores para 2030 yo digo que es
la base mínima para afrontar el reto
alimentario y el reto agroecológico esto
implica instalar entre 20 mil y 25 mil
agricultores al año lo que supone un
esfuerzo gigantesco cuando hoy solo
estamos instalando la mitad
pueden ser rivales pero riquísimo imagen
depende al menos están de acuerdo en que
el problema viene del extranjero
la gran mayoría de la gente del campo es
ahora víctima de una delincuencia
inaceptable que es la delincuencia
itinerante a menudo de origen extranjero
hay que decir una cosa china
me gustaría que dejáramos de firmar
acuerdos de libre comercio con todo el
mundo una competencia desleal imposible
de vivir a dibujo los agricultores
llevan mucho tiempo en el corazón de ro
la sal es hijo y nieto de un pastor de
los agricultores no son el enemigo no
son los que contaminan no son los que
calientan el planeta y al menos no
mienten como nosotros los políticos
mante para comer nuevo la política
una semana en donde al lado de la
agricultura estuvo presente el tema
pensional jubilación a los 65 años con
mayores condiciones para el ingreso de
solidaridad activa rsa este es el plan
de manny el marco de tener una segunda
temporada en el elíseo es un viraje
hacia la derecha según la socialista
anne hidalgo
estabilizar a estas personas y tratar a
quienes los ayudan de cobardes es este
el plan de emanuel macu esa es la famosa
francia que caminaría sobre las dos
piernas la pierna derecha y la izquierda
de momento saltas solo sobre una pierna
pero sobre todo con el pie derecho
con su propuesta de retiro a los 60 años
el líder de francia en su misa se ha
convertido en la pesadilla de manuel
marco imagen leo penn y
el del señor macrón es el programa
económico de la señora el epen más el
desprecio de clase el de la señora le
pen es el programa económico del señor
macro más el desprecio racial
en bicicleta y con una sonrisa y anexado
representante de los verdes se presentó
a su primer gran encuentro
y jóvenes de francia hagan presencia en
este escrutinio vengan a respaldarlos
con sus deseos únase a nosotros en mi
campaña
[Aplausos]
con sueño
el sueño
esto es todo por esta semana hasta la
próxima
el presidente de manuel majo bajó un
poco en las encuestas aunque la sigue
liderando el mandatario tiene un 28 por
ciento de intención de voto mientras que
la ultraconservadora ma jin de penn le
ha acortado ventaja y ahora tiene un 20%
el izquierdistas jean luc mélenchon
también ha aumentado un poco de situarse
en el 15% si los dos primeros candidatos
pasan la segunda vuelta mayor le ganaría
al epen aunque el margen de diferencia
es cada vez más apretado y ya están a
tan solo 10 puntos porcentuales
y en medio de su disminución a los
sondeos por primera vez en la campaña
electoral emanuel bajo salió a las
calles a promocionar su reelección el
candidato estuvo primero en la población
de fuga en el oeste de francia y un día
después viajó a la ciudad de dijon y es
que ante la abstención que podría ser
más alta de lo normal bajo intentar
reforzar su apoyo luego de haber tenido
gran parte de su atención mediando en la
guerra en ucrania
y su ausencia en la campaña electoral no
es el único problema que enfrenta bajo
el senado francés publicó un informe en
el que reveló que bajo su mandato el
gasto estatal con consultoras se disparó
a más de mil millones de euros
incluyendo la firma mckinsey los rivales
de mayor aprovechando el escándalo para
criticarlo aunque el presidente se
defiende podría definirse como una
respuesta para el control de daños el
miércoles 30 de marzo dos ministros del
gabinete francés ofrecieron una rueda de
prensa para defender las acusaciones de
gasto excesivo y de socavar el sistema
de funcionarios públicos según un
informe del senado el gobierno del
presidente francés emmanuel macrón gastó
casi mil millones de euros el año pasado
en consultoras entre ellas la firma
estadounidense mckinsey and con un gasto
que se duplicó con creces entre 2018 y
2021 pero ante las que el gobierno se
defiende de quienes lo acusan de
adicción al gasto y huila google nuevo
así un pleno si el gobierno acepta
plenamente que en estas circunstancias
excepcionales ha tenido que recurrir a
refuerzos más allá de la indispensable
continuidad de los públicos de la
gestión 24/7 de kobe 19 y de estas
consecuencias económicas y sociales
aceptamos también que había que
transformar nuestro país para obtener
los resultados lo más rápidamente
posible al servicio de los franceses
georges no pues sí o sea bis de jose
otra cuestión que se destaca en el
informe y que está siendo utilizada como
munición por los rivales de macrón tanto
en la izquierda como la derecha son los
asuntos fiscales de mckinsey ya que no
ha pagado el impuesto de sociedades
entre 2011 y 2020 algo a lo que los
ministros se apresuraron a responder
usted de un patadón futbolista 7 el
impago de impuestos de sociedades no
está vinculado sistemáticamente a la
evasión o al fraude deliberado no se
paga el impuesto de sociedades cuando no
se obtienen beneficios reales el asunto
mckean se preocupa a los partidarios de
macrón mientras que algunos quieren
contraatacar diciendo que todas las
administraciones extranjeras recurren a
consultoras globales como lo han hecho
anteriores gobiernos franceses otros
temen que el caso y adiciones más leña
al fuego a los rivales de la campaña a
tan sólo 10 días para que comience la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
en cuanto a los partidos de izquierda en
francia todos unidos representan apenas
el 30 por ciento de las intenciones de
voto sean lucro alan son el candidato
del partido francia insumisa tiene la
mitad de ese porcentaje y encarna la
última esperanza para los más
progresistas de llegar a una segunda
vuelta gabriel coll quien nos cuenta por
qué la izquierda llega a fragmentada
históricamente el partido socialista
llegaba sin esfuerzos a la segunda
vuelta de la elección presidencial hoy
reunió sólo el 2% de las intenciones de
voto el mandato decepcionante de fonz
balón de 2012 a 2017 participó en
debilitar al ps pero también la
transformación de los equilibrios de
poder entre derecha e izquierda con un
surgimiento de la extrema derecha en los
últimos 20 años es la correlación de
fuerzas entre la derecha e izquierda que
ha ido cambiando y eso pone en peligro y
luego lo ha pasado ya dos veces en el
2002 y el 2010 2017 pone en peligro la
presencia de la izquierda en la segunda
vuelta con un partido tradicional
debilitado la izquierda hacia fragmento
7 de los 12 candidatos que aspiran al
elíseo pertenecen a ese espectro
político la primaria popular fue una
iniciativa que buscaba unir esfuerzos
detrás de un solo candidato pero fue un
fracaso la ganadora cristian tuviera ni
siquiera obtuvo los apoyos necesarios
para calificar su candidatura pero se
puede no ser el problema principal su
cobertura el problema de la izquierda no
es que haya varias candidaturas siempre
fue así y nunca impidió a la izquierda
ganaron la abstención podría ser
determinante menos del 70% de los
franceses están seguros de ir a votar el
10 de abril estamos hablando de todavía
45 millones de gente en particular de
los sectores populares más pobres o
menos diplomas menos ingresos que no van
a ir a votar eso este el problema
principal de la izquierda
más que la unidad de los partidos las
clases populares son las que más
desconfían en la política y johnny no
son una opción más extrema que el ps se
planta como la única opción de la
izquierda de llegar a la segunda vuelta
un especialista en éxito el socialismo
ya no existe el único que nos puede
salvar ahora es milán son gemelos o
actualmente el candidato de la france en
su misa es tercero en las encuestas
así llegamos al final de este programa
espero en nuestro especial sobre las
elecciones de francia el domingo 10 de
abril analizaremos todo lo que ocurre en
la primera vuelta de las presidenciales
nos vemos